so when it comes to social media in the
workplace there are some important
things employees should keep in mind
here to break it down for us is eric
palacios of eric palacios and associates
the sponsor of this next segment
let's talk about social media and as an
employee can i be fired for something i
say on social media or say other
comments over emails can you break that
down for us well it depends on a lot of
different things but nevada has what's
called a right to work law
means you can fire someone without
giving them any reason so in nevada if
you do something that your boss doesn't
approve uh he can just simply say uh
you're no longer needed your employment
is terminated without explaining why
they're letting you go
so yes if you post something your boss
sees that your manager sees it it's
something that
is offensive or
results in the business suffering a loss
their clients being offended uh clients
leaving the business causing them a
monetary loss then they can always say
that's the reason why we're letting you
go or simply they can let you go and not
give you a reason
and i think a lot of us are confused a
little bit when it comes to privacy is
our social media actually considered
private
it can be if you have all the settings
set correctly but uh the majority of
people post things that are either not
private uh so others can see it or that
post is shared and then somebody that
you're friends with is friends with a
boss a manager in your company and their
eyes get to see it so you have to be
careful on what you post especially if
you're doing it during work hours or on
a work computer or ipad then your boss
has more reason to check it to monitor
it and then to use it against you now by
law in nevada your boss your manager
can't uh make you accept them as a
friend or accept that they follow you on
social media so that
is one of your rights that you have here
in nevada but in the most part anything
you post count on somebody either
telling them about it or them being able
to see it
well it's all really important
information and just good to keep in
mind and really quickly here if we have
freedom of speech why do people get
fired or are forced to resign
when they're just speaking freely
and that's the other argument it's well
what a person said was said 10 years ago
15 years ago and it wasn't during
company time
it was it should be something that's
personal or private the problem is any
negative comment that affects the
business in a negative way
here for instance
raiders might lose a lot of fans a lot
of ticket sales and just uh goodwill
because
somebody that made those comments is
allowed to remain a part of the
organization so
can the franchise fire
someone
they can but in this instance they're
urged to resign to make it easier for
everybody and basically saying
do the right thing and take care of this
yourself rather than having us
take care of this
well thank you so much for breaking all
this down really important information
we appreciate you taking the time and we
will see you next time
thank you for having me see you soon
for more information give eric palacios
and associates a call at 702-444-7777